look at Paul versus K inside when is it
going to end
oh okay well then tell them I ate it's
my duty to see this thing through
I wasn't originally going to make a
video on this but it seems like new
things it's just happening every single
day
at first we were greeted with these face
to face videos and you may think wow
that might be interesting finally they
talk face to face and we actually get to
hear what they say it's gonna be
interesting this one no no it isn't I
can summarize it as this jg calls Jake
Paul a [ __ ] about ten times does that
energy being a [ __ ] relief yeah okay
what short version is that is she being
a [ __ ] really he makes a video calling
me a [ __ ] like 50 times and he's only
won that last joke I remember you said
I'm too scared to call you a [ __ ] in
your face like to your face you're a
[ __ ] I'm saying it to your face now
you're a [ __ ] cool yeah I remember you
said you're gonna do something I'll call
you a [ __ ] I'm calling you a [ __ ] now
yeah yeah honestly I just can't play
you're a [ __ ] I'm saying it or in case
you're wondering when the fight is that
it was also talked about just a couple
of times
no August may fish your man obviously
fit I don't miss 25th August honey fifth
always fight for who's gonna be the best
ksi face-to-face appeared and it was
equally uninteresting basically a
drinking water competition I'm in your
head I think we have a problem
don't worry I'll put that hand back what
are you doing
you might hmm at least they're hydrated
that's always a good thing to know
it's about fit what better outfit then
lost time yeah yeah
thanks you two Alexa this is so nice
two people they hate each other can come
together while wearing their favorite
Walmart finally they get along this
really warms my heart case I talked
about how he destroyed Weller I
destroyed Willa what do you think of
that
let's just hope this fight is a bit more
interesting than the case I versus Joe
Weller fight right hook by JJ another
chop idrija Jordan not answering Joe
hasn't thrown a punch yet Joe needs to
start throwing Joe needs to throw Johnny
and he does and he does draw a knee
lunge
this is Joe sitting back waiting to go
in the final press conference Logan took
a big al he basically cried on stage
you
de Logan decided mm-hmm no no he's gonna
make a response video to explain why he
left the press conference called dear
care site here's why I walked up stage
Oh goddamn if you thought the last press
conference was a disaster this one was a
major disaster if you're wondering why
his voice is so high right now well
there's a simple reason for that well
you know because I'm vegan now
in this video Logan explains the madness
that went on behind the scenes people
were crazy
his dad even got punched when we tried
to get out they were kicking our cars
the gold rolls and the gold Bentley kids
were like climbing on top of buildings
and she punched in the back of the head
my dad did he deserve it maybe this
video is very well-crafted
and I'm gonna go through widest piece by
piece and it starts now he's calling out
the madness of this event and he's
shifting the blame of that and the
reason his dad got pushed to Deji and
then I remembered dad she told them to
be in London it's to do to me okay we'll
shake you twister light believe it
that's what we do digi is clearly joking
this is a clever way for Logan to get
the moral high ground oh it was so bad
how everything was out of control it
would have gotten out of control
regardless of JJ's comment you know that
that's a fact so that's the first thing
he does and that's the thing a lot of
people as soon as he saw this Logan
Paulin video they were like oh I'm all
I'm on board with Logan Paul train now
really really he then for some reason
calls out ksi for just recycling jokes
that's all he did during the press
conference what that joke was used in
the last press conference but apparently
we're recycling content okay
pretty good joke I'm not gonna lie he
got me good there but again I saw you
tweeted about this already like multiple
times I guess I just was confused I
didn't know we're still recycling
content but okay just delusional times
it's so crazy cuz I just thinking back I
feel like he said the same thing in the
first press conference but the
statistical brother
are we still recycling content Wow these
brothers sure are creative Wow these
brothers sure whoa at least I didn't
recycle my favorite punch like Walmart
at least I have enough integrity not to
do that Logan the only thing you said in
the entire press conference the one
thing you said was a recycled joke
you can't call out ksi for recycling
jokes it doesn't work funny to hear you
talk about your baby carrot dick keep
going I enjoy it grew little dick today
yo and I'm vegan and I'm vegan so I
recognized a baby carrot when I see one
ha ha ha ha ha baby carrot small penis
you have small penis well you dress bad
well you're a [ __ ] the insults I really
appreciate then he goes on and bring in
the reason why the reason why he walked
out of the press conference the reason
why he didn't say anything you know why
it was it wasn't because he was scared
it wasn't because he looked like he was
about to cry it was because of the
moderator that's right everybody
pools pool but whatever man so I'm
thinking why it is just so one-sided why
did the moderator let JJ talk for 5
minutes and 20 seconds straight yes I
timed it and why are we not talking
about the fight and then I remembered
holy asshat
this dude's King hates me bullying Paul
this kids are big on YouTube out America
just a douche bag joke why he's not
hurting anyone you know he's a [ __ ]
idiot for who cares he's not that is the
nicest thing I have ever heard
anyone explain Logan Paul he's an idiot
but he's not hurting anyone you should
be thanking him that's like a compliment
for your standard Logan so the moderator
made a response to this true Jordy here
a response to Logan poll or as he likes
to call me the moderator PewDiePie
called me the ref you know can we just
get this straight true Jordy true
journey true charity I'm sorry I'm sorry
please don't hurt me okay
Jordy got it and why are we not talking
about the fight maybe because you didn't
say a thing word man I love that
response why did he just speak for 5
minutes I don't understand maybe because
you didn't say anything he then calls
out true Jordy for not being neutral for
for being on the side of ksi I just
don't think the memory of the press
conference the person who should be
neutral the person who should be the one
driving the conversation should be a
Logan and Jake Paul hater skin early
said
he's an idiot but he's not hurting
anyone wow what a hater and if it's a
problem that he's neutral this argument
is so ridiculous because literally the
tec-9 looking guy I'm sorry I don't know
your name please don't hurt me there
please they're clearly friends too even
in the press conference he was standing
on the side of the polls I remember this
look at he's right there next to Greg
Paul's dead what is he doing this I
thought he was supposed to be neutral
apparently that's a big issue so Logan
poll went out of his way to make sure
that true Jordy wasn't going to
commentate over this fight because he
commented on the original fight with ksi
so he doesn't want him to commentate
because he's not neutral apparently when
in reality I think he did a really good
job considering all the circumstances
apparently they settle it and on a phone
call or something like that and he is
actually going to comment on the fight
most likely not because Logan Paul is a
nice person but because people were
outraged and pissed off that he was and
go I'm going to be allowed to do it but
so there's a reason I walked out there's
a reason I keep saying I'm done with the
talk that's the reason why everybody
that's the reason why I walked out not
because I had nothing to say and I was
literally on the verge of tears
think about how much money you're gonna
make out of this event bag it shouldn't
be that hard to go through all this so
shifting blame taking the moral high
ground but now is when the video really
take that it's deepest turn the exact
person that I am working hard not to
become I made an unforgivable mistake
back in January and no one is ever gonna
forget that that is part of my life now
I am the one what end of every single
day I have to look in the mirror and ask
myself what the wrong in my life where I
thought that was a good idea Logan Paul
place the moral high ground and I guess
again is cave site that's not really
hard to do but for Logan Paul to do this
it's a it's interesting it's very
interesting and a lot of people bought
it and he does it really well because he
has a strong argument for example ksi I
did not want to take the low blows I did
not want to get personal but you bring
it on my girlfriend Chloe Bennet
what's up babes
now Ches I he is a scumbag you're both
scumbags in case I has made same
comments about my future wife Marcia
it's it and I never respond to it
because it's just cringing so if
anything I understand why Logan didn't
respond here cuz it's like it's it's
such a low comment that is literally
only going to respond to the 12 year
olds in an audience like this but anyone
else will see it and be like yeah that's
really dumb like that's really pathetic
that's a stupid ass comment so Logan
really has to offer our hand here to
play the moral high ground and be like
and all this just so bad I can't believe
you treat my girlfriend like an object
and he does it very well after you said
this about Chloe in your last video
how's he gonna go down on you a busted
lip I'm sorry Chloe but after the 24th
of August Logan's gonna have to [ __ ] you
like a prostitute if you know what I
mean and then he shows all clips of ksi
when he went to conventions and making
sexist comments to the show both girls
massive tits where have your tits gone
where'd the god
because I can't see them and also the
comments he made about his friends
little sister cause I'm gonna explore
her purpose
I think that us girls need to kind of
stand up for ourselves so he brings up
the past behavior kids irony associated
with the current behavior of chaos I'm
very clever very smart he's got him now
but he doesn't just stop there he goes
after his brands six years you're still
doing the same even when I warned you
even off-camera when I tried to make it
clear that this was going somewhere I
did not want it to go
how do people not know about how do you
have a brand deal with EA or any big
brands for that matter Logan must be
really pissed we're going after brand
deals then ksi is got working I think
that's a really low blow as well hey if
not equally vicious because he was
essentially going after K XY's
livelihood but then he does even better
is that he protects himself from the
same criticism Logan is not innocent of
doing this exact same thing ksi did
typically with my music video no
handlebars
[Music]
where he made this song about handlebars
and he can ride girls were there or
whatever it's got 42 million views this
type of content no longer accurately
represents my brand and the person that
I am becoming okay so this is no
handlebars I'm going over and I am
deleting it from YouTube
so he protects himself from the same
criticism even though he's really just
being a hypocrite
what's even better by this is that this
song had a lot of drama related to it
because it's blatant plagiarism anyone
that's heard the original song that this
is based on know that that's a fact even
the creators of the song went out and
said this is so dumb I can ride my bike
with no handlebars no handlebars no
handlebars and I can own it it's the
same song you just made it the same song
except it's sexist logan paul edition
but you deleted it so you know KCI is
really the bad one here he's really the
problem and then he goes even further to
paint caves I a villain by I can't
believe I'm defending kiss I hear it's
so stupid but he goes on and and and
making him seem like he has a giant ego
by calling himself a God and doing his
face to face things but this kid
literally looked me in the eye and told
me he was God g.od god that's where his
head is that right now I wouldn't get
I'm an animal I'm a dog brony there were
two of them of gold you're you're a god
this is what God looks like Jesus Christ
we got some work to do white one what my
son yeah it's funny it's a joke you told
me a joke just like you're calling
yourself an animal you don't think
you're an animal you don't think you're
a dog so case I made a response to this
you should check it out he basically
dispute all these claims saying that the
clip of him saying that Chloe was a
prostitute
it wasn't implying that she was a
prostitute just like Kate Logan will
have such a broken lips that she's not
gonna want to kiss him like you don't
want to kiss a prostitute the Caspar Lee
clip was basically unrelated to his
event anyway so you're just lying there
as well so this video you know I'll give
it props for bleeding for being well put
together and clever but it just shows
how Logan will take any step even if
it's lying cuz I don't think it was
wrong for being pissed off about the
girlfriend comment I get that but the
way he goes about it attacking his
brands and all these things
he just doesn't care you have other
girls who used to know ksi saying that
if Logan Paul ever makes a comment about
respecting women he is full of Sh
there's so many other videos where Logan
is equally bad as ksi in my opinion
probably delete this video as well this
idea where I would ride them but like
but like a bicycle not in the sexual way
so we're gonna make this thing as
formation out of people it's called the
human but we're gonna put the girls and
me on this platform and then roll down
it looks kind of ridiculous like this so
yeah except it's gonna be for girls than
me the issue is that we haven't told
them we're doing this yet so that should
be fun on this video shifting Blaine's
taking the moral high ground making all
kinds of lives and claims the thing is I
had beef with both ksi and Logan but the
thing is these guys are just purely
driven by money this whole event is
going to make them a lot of money if
Logan thinks he's going to make more
money by being a nice guy he's going to
pretend to be a nice guy
Logan Willard is the kind of person that
will be whatever it takes for him to get
what he wants
I'm gonna be the guy they think I am and
I essentially became the architect of my
own destruction because I wanted to be
who they thought I thought I might as
well adopt this adopt this screw it and
it wasn't that a direct contradiction to
everything you just put out about how
you're changing and how you're a
different person I do want to give
people a second chance I think they
deserve it but when people blatantly lie
and other people are buying into it I
saw a lot of people saw this video and
be like whoa I'm on board over ball now
I feel like it's I have to call it out
that being said this video has been
extremely long and I hope I don't have
to make another video because I honestly
I don't care
between ksi and low
who do I think should win the thing is
Logan can't lose if he loses I think
people will sympathize with him and if
he wins he wins if K Desai loses he's
just gonna look like an idiot because
case I says he wants to do professional
boxing now which if you lose against a
youtuber that career is over before it's
begun
I think case I will win and I don't
think it really matters what happens to
Logan if anything he's in a really good
position right now he all he has to do
is stop lying that's all you got to do
stop lying
great this is this video leave a thumbs
up if you enjoyed watching it we'd
really much appreciated subscribe if
you're not subscribed already I also
have new March wack Donald's track dogs
whatever if you want to embrace the
aesthetic oh that you're working in a
fast-food restaurant check out the link
in the description yes that's right we
do the finest merch for you 9 year olds
it was designed by me I hope you guys
like it
there is the limited time only and a
good buy